the best exchange with Hunter was Far
and Away not with any of the members of
Congress it was with a reporter who
asked the question that was on all of
our minds let me make a statement crack
do you normally smoke
Mr this is how Hunter Biden should be
dealt with on Capitol Hill okay Hunter
Biden is showing up to Capitol Hill not
to answer the legitimate questions of
congress not to face consequences for
his crimes that have been caught on tape
for years and years and years some of
which are not not just Petty personal
sexual crimes and Drug crimes but but
actually pretty serious political crimes
he is there to try to win public
sympathy he is there to make the case
that he's actually a victim of a Witch
Hunt he's there to to move the polls and
so knowing that understanding that
that's what this is really about the way
to deal with Hunter Biden is to give as
good as as as he does